[Music]
we have linked up with the curiosity
event um to give students an insight
into finance careers in finance and west
suffolk college particularly in the
courses and offer of finance and
business that we offer to students
we're at the john peel centre in stone
market and we're doing a course in
finances and at the moment we're running
like a kind of simulation of a stock
market and we have to buy and sell
shares to try and make a profit so what
we've noticed recently is students have
been really involved in the stock market
banking finance
and with the media increasing and
influencing in the stock market uh
students are really intrigued into
what's happening so we wanted to give
them an opportunity
to have a have a go at investing in the
stock market
and seeing how fluctuation changes and
the media effect and most importantly on
the stock market
um they're working really well so
they're really enjoying what they're
doing it's the idea of using maths but
in an applied way so actually if you do
it well enough you don't even notice
you're doing it
that's the strengths of these kind of
events in college we like to turn things
practical skills music into vocational
job related activities so in this way
they've actually if you work in finance
you need to work with numbers accounts
you need to work numbers and what we're
doing here is we're applying that
directly to stocks and shares i've got
an auntie that works in banking and
[Music]
it's just a career path that seems
interesting so i thought i'd come along
see what it's about
i came along because um i've i've always
not really i've had some some ideas on
what i want my future job to be i
haven't really had any concrete ideas so
i thought i'd explore something new
which i'll soon be pretty successful
throughout the years so i thought this
would be a good one to try out
basically i had a week it seemed
interesting and potentially looking at a
career in something financially i found
out i think it was through
through school so school email or on a
facebook page i think
the stock market is directly affected by
the news but not necessarily how you
would expect but if you
keep in touch with the news so in this
activity here they're given some
information about what's happening in
global events and then obviously it
links to how the stock prices change or
fluctuate
and that's advice actually for the real
world so when you deal with the stock
market in the real world um you really
need to be
abreast about what's happening in the
world so you need to be have
bbc app on your phone follow the news so
you actually know what's happening
because that will directly filter
through to prices
[Music]